c'est l'une des trois plus grandes
entreprises de gestion de réservation
touristique une entreprise américaine
texane plus précisément qui s'appelle
sabres sabres connaît probablement le
siège sur lequel vous étiez assis lors
de votre précédent vol en avion
elle s'est aussi probablement dans quel
hôtel vous avez réservé pour vos
dernières vacances car le groupe de 9000
employés traitent plus d'un tiers de
toutes les réservations de voyages
aériens dans le monde ce qui équivaut à
260 milliards de dollars de dépenses par
an et possède un trésor de données
précieuses dont le fbi se serviraient
pour surveiller les voyageurs
c'est en tout cas ce qu'a révélé le
magazine forbes le fbi a ils se serrent
secrètement d'une entreprise de voyages
pesant 2 milliards de dollars comme
outil de surveillance globale ces
données forbes révèle que sabres les a
transmises aux nba et a parfois même
suivi un voyageur en temps réel pour le
compte de l' agence fédérale
la quantité de données que stoke sabre
est tellement importante qu'elle
permette aux autorités américaines de
couvrir un large faisceau d'informations
avec les institutions financières ou le
secteur des télécommunications
le gouvernement doit s'adresser à chaque
banque ou opérateurs et lui transmettre
une ordonnance il pourrait adopter une
approche similaire avec le secteur du
voyage
en procédant de même avec chaque
compagnie aérienne hôtels et agences de
réservation mais avec sabre ou l'un de
ses principaux concurrents le
gouvernement peut avoir accès à
l'ensemble des bases de données avec une
seule ordonnance
le gouvernement américain se serait
ainsi appuyé sur l'entreprise pour
retracer et suivre les mouvements des
terroristes du 11 septembre mais elle
peut aussi par exemple informé le fbi
hayon ton réel des déplacements d'un
fugitif ordonnance à l'appui l'article
démontre comment décembre 2019 l'état
californien a demandé au groupe des
informations sur un citoyen indien qu'il
considérait comme un fugitif
le gouvernement demande en outre à
sabres qu'elles fournissent aux
représentants du fbi des informations
complètes et en temps réel sur
l'activité du voyageur sur une base
hebdomadaire et continue pendant une
période de six mois
des demandes rendue possible par une loi
datant de 1789 est dénommée alouite acte
avec cette loi remet les
autorités américaines peuvent
contraindre une tierce personne à aider
à l'application d'une décision de
justice et donc des entreprises à
divulguer des informations sur un
individu
c'est d'ailleurs en se servant de cette
loi que la police américaine avait tenté
de forcer apple à déverrouiller le
téléphone du terroriste de san
bernardino en 2015 mais selon l'article
de forme outre les fugitifs les
autorités américaines pourraient se
servir de cet outil pour surveiller par
exemple la propagation d'une épidémie
comme celle du scolyte 19
tant que le gouvernement pourra s'en
tirer impunément avec des ordonnances
secrète transmises à des entreprises qui
n'offrent aucune résistance et que les
juges continueront à signer les
ordonnances que le gouvernement rédige
pour elle nous ne saurons rien
impossible donc d'avoir une idée de la
fréquence ou l'échelle à laquelle les
autorités américaines ont recours à ce
dispositif pour forcer les entreprises
détenant des masses de données à
collaborer si l'intention du fbi se
borne à arrêter des criminels
cela semble légitime mais comme on a pu
le lire dans l'autobiographie d'edward
snowdon lusage de données personnelles
dans un contexte opaque peut facilement
déboucher sur des dérives